hey there welcome to conan o'brien needs
a friend
um
that's a legitimate opening to the show
that's the problem that's that that we
we do so much [ __ ] right before and
you're like okay everybody stop and then
you're like hello there like yeah i know
we've talked about this before but it
never stops being funny well you know
what okay let's be honest with the
listener that uh seconds before i said
hey there and welcome
we were babbling back and forth
and sona you've been using a lot of
armenian words today yes now uh the one
that you just used just seconds before
we started matt burped
yeah and then you said something what
did you say i said ah nush anush
because i'm speaking armenian to my
babies
so when they burp or you know fart or
something i go on
which means like i hope
you i hope that was delicious
i hope that was delicious i hope like
whatever made you do that was delicious
oh i see i see
no no like i hope like i know that
you're belching because you ate
something like i hope it was good and
that's that's
okay i'm gonna use that with my daughter
yeah yeah yeah it's nice the other one
uh is i you and i have been friends for
a long time yeah and when i get
comfortable with people i sometimes when
i see them i grab them by the shoulders
and i give them a little pat on the back
and then you get comfortable
five minutes after meeting someone
you'll do that
six minutes
but um anyway i saw you uh today and uh
sometimes you'll strike me and maybe
i'll give you a little pat on the back
you grab and you shake a like i grab a
nice shake to try and improve people's
circulation oh is that like you're
you're really dancing the line to sit
make sure people know you're not like
abusing people
you are abusing people you've abused
blay for a long time well blai uh for a
while i was trying to teach him to be a
you know um what to do in an attack
so i would i would strike him
occasionally and and blay uh you were
fine with it weren't you
uh okay we're good okay that's all the
time we have yeah so sona
um i was giving you like a little oh a
sona and i grabbed you i was excited to
see you and i gave you a little shake
and you said i said come on
and i say i say that to my boys who are
10 months old one of them especially i
say to charlie one of them especially is
10 months old
especially i say it more often because
he's very rough and he you know he's
still learning about his body so i'm
like come on it's whenever he's like
petting and what does gamotz mean it
means like
slowly like gently be gentle
and when you were like shaking me and uh
you know being conan
i said it to you
almost instinctively the way i say it to
my little baby so the relationship you
have with your 10 months old yeah 10
month old twins is the same relationship
you have with me i'm trying to teach him
how to be a human being yes this makes
sense and i say the things to him that i
i say to you what i say to him when i'm
teaching him how to be a functioning
human what's the um you're teaching you
want them to be
only no armenian or do you also want
them to know english i don't want them
to know english at all
[Laughter]
that's what i was getting to you want
them to be strangers in a strange land
their whole life they want them to have
little accents
now is how does that work how do you
balance it between english and armenian
at home usually we speak to them mostly
in armenian wait but you they need to
know english too they'll learn my first
language was armenian and i learned
english
well you have problems what your g's are
very hard her g's are very nice
yeah okay
[Laughter]
you're right you know what that's very
soothing when you say good morning
they say if one parent speaks them only
in whatever language and then the other
one speaks them in english they can just
grow up being bilingual which is what
we're hoping for or speak neither
language really properly yeah
that's another possibility yeah okay i
mean english yeah learn english yeah
yeah that's true i mean it's yeah but
gamat i'm going to say that to you from
now on i grew up my parents uh who are
you know super hardcore irish catholics
and my life was filled with these
phrases and words that i realized later
on other people don't use every single
day what yeah my mom would call say like
you're being a bold stump oh yes i love
you you know i told you that
but also jesus mary and joseph was
something that i heard that every three
seconds
i don't like that even fool yeah like
that even falling well that's not i
don't know if that's an irish thing that
was more of just uh
i don't like that even fool but why do
you speak so much nonsense
gibberish yes so much i think it's in
the blood i mean you know the the irish
love to invent words
after drinking
okay that's wow
incredible and again i'm going to repeat
it's the last ethnic group we are the
last
group you can make fun of and nobody
just assaulted her for being an army
yeah i didn't assault her for being an
armenian i just think you have to choose
a language and stick with it oh okay
okay no and it's it's just that that's
recorded yeah yeah um you're right
there's no movement to get rid of the
leprechaun from you know uh was it
lucky charms yeah yeah of course not or
they changed the notre dame mascot or
the celtics
yeah yeah because where are they going
to go from there a banshee no it's
downward no no
i'm irish i can say this oh you're irish
oh my god how much irish are you
how much you're probably like one
fifteenth irish and the rest is i'm i'm
scott's irish okay that's not irish the
longer that we do this the more i
realize you two are very similar how
dare you i'm sorry
if i say oh i went to harry truman's by
his uh you know house the other day you
guys would be like oh my god the one i
saw you there yeah
i can't believe we haven't passed each
other in all these different historic
sites i know it's just a goddamn hipster
but i'll say that growing up they're
just all these different words that i
realized were just sort of in the
bloodstream but the big thing is i grew
up my father invented words his father
invented words my grandfather on my
mother's side invented what do you
remember any my dad when we were he
wanted us to get going he'd say come on
we gotta flang it and swang it
we gotta plant it and swing it let's go
wait a minute that when you say that
seems very sexual and when you say we
want this to get going we gotta flang it
and swing it yeah it's his dad it's my
dad when i was a kid don't be a creep
but anyway i don't think i'm the creeper
i like playing and swinging i like that
that's like a wedding night
in my life i mean i didn't do it all the
years broadcasting
but in my everyday life i'm mostly
speaking invented words yeah yeah and um
it's just complete nonsense and i
remember talking to my dad about it once
and i was trying to come up with an
intellectual cool reason why
we do this and i said you know and i had
read this once there's a theory
that the uh the irish love to
destroy and bend and twist language like
james joyce we love to do it we love to
do it because it's a rebellion against
the english language that was imposed on
us
by the scots irish yeah no that was
imposed on us by the uh you know the
british overlords that and that took
over our country
and um enforce their language upon us
and this was our rebellion and i had
this whole articulate argument for why
this was like a beautiful form of
rebellion my father cut me off and went
no no no no we do it because we can't
help it
and i realize yeah it's right it's just
a weird compulsion we have
to make up yeah [ __ ] words yeah and
um use them and and babble away so yeah
yeah anyway well it was like that mug
that greg daniels got you that was on
your desk for true story yeah uh when i
started my late night show in september
of 1993
just before i went on the air my um
my writing partner greg daniels
who went on to
huge success
he did so much better without me uh
once he got rid of when he got rid of
the albatross that was going yeah the
dead weight
um he blew up but uh but he gave me this
mug that i
kept on my uh i had the eisenhower
um mug that robert smile gave me years
ago that i had on my desk it's saturday
night live and i had this drinking mug
and it was one that uh greg made
and he painted on it all the words
that i would
babble
that i had made up
um gibberish and nonsense and so i still
have that mug to this day
uh and it was on my desk every episode
of all the different shows that i had
yeah that memorializes that this has
been a problem for me
my entire life yeah yeah uh he did that
but you know we can't waste any more
time i suggest we flying it and swaying
it
excuse me
excuse me human resources